beautiful girl warms the heart of a
cursed beast but what if the beast
wasn't the best option for Val we're
here to tell you all the reasons that
Belle should have ended up with Gaston
instead of the Beast what the 1991
animated movie Beauty and the Beast is
one of the most iconic fairytales of all
time when Disney decided to take on the
old French story it stole the hearts of
people everywhere
it's a classic happily ever after the
doll was the first princess to have a
more dynamic personality Val isman
venters daughter in a small French
village she hates her poor provincial
life and uses reading to escape she's
quiet and smart and always has her nose
stuck in a book the other villagers
think she's odd and just don't like her
everyone except Gaston that is Gaston is
the most popular man in the village he
is a war veteran and he thinks really
highly of himself women throw themselves
at him but he only has eyes for belle of
course he wants to marry her because she
is the most beautiful girl in town
snakey will marry me he tries to propose
to her rather forcefully but she rejects
him Belle's father gets taken prisoner
by the Beast the Beast was a prince he
was so cruel that he and his whole
castle were cursed his household staff
are enchanted objects he lives in
solitude and he is totally miserable he
will be doomed to be a beast forever
unless he can find true love Belle comes
to free her father the household objects
think that Belle could be the one to
break the curse unfortunately the Beast
is kind of a monster he's mean and has
some serious anger issues Belle's father
Maurice tries to recruit Gaston and the
villagers to help rescue Belle but they
think he's crazy
meanwhile Belle starts to realize that
maybe the Beast isn't all bad they fall
in love Belle comes back to save her
father from being put in a mental asylum
she uses the beasts mirror to prove that
Maurice isn't crazy the villagers are
terrified Gaston uses their fear to
rally their support they march to the
castle to fight the Beast
gasps bond and the beasts have a
showdown in Gaston falls off the castle
the spell breaks and Belle lives happily
ever after as a princess
Gaston seems like a terrible choice for
a husband but if you dig a little deeper
you might realize he's not all that bad
there are several theories that suggest
he's the way better choice and he also
has some redeeming qualities I'm just
full of surprises let's take a look at
some of his better characteristics my
what a guy that Gaston Gaston 'zv Estie
Lefou has no problem finding good traits
in Gaston he sings a whole song about it
no one fights like Gaston no one breaks
hearts or eats as many eggs as Gaston
and Gaston seems to think he's perfect
but we aren't talking about all of these
reasons that Gaston isn't such a
terrible guy an episode up tuned up
makes some great points about Gaston's
character when compared to the beast
first of all the beast keeps a ton of
secrets there's a whole wing of his
castle that Belle can't go to he doesn't
tell Belle why his whole castle is
enchanted so she probably feels pretty
crazy with talking teapots around and
when she finds the rose he doesn't tell
her what is for if she's supposed to be
there her whole life she kind of
deserves to know Gaston is not a
secretive guy he says exactly what is on
his mind
the whole village knew when he was going
to propose Cadell honesty is the best
policy
in any relationship Gaston is a healthy
guy he doesn't eat fancy multi-course
meals all the time he's in great shape
though wouldn't have to worry about
becoming a widow anytime soon he's also
got a better living situation than the
Beast he lives in town near the library
that Belle loves so much
he's also near her father the Beast
lives in a lonely isolated castle you
can't even go hiking in the woods near
the castle because of the terrifying
man-eating wolves speaking of those
wolves Gaston is a hunter and a former
soldier he totally protects Belle Gaston
is also better-looking than the Beast at
least before the curse is broken
for one thing he's human and though he
says every last inch of him is covered
in hair he's clearly exaggerating have
you ever seen the Beast he is way
hairier belen Gaston would have
good-looking kids Gaston is not nearly
as lazy as the Beast
he lives alone so if he knows how to do
stuff around the house do you think they
would ever get the beast to help put
together her new bookshelf no he is a
prince he wouldn't even know where to
start
Gaston hunts so he could provide plenty
of meat for the table and while Gaston
clearly has some major falls he isn't
mean enough to get cursed we're looking
at you Beast
Gaston may be arrogant and superficial
but he didn't refuse an old woman to
stay in his castle during a storm
we're just saying there's a big
difference between being a snob and
being cruel finally Gaston is ready to
settle down the Beast has no desire to
fall in love even though he needs to in
order to break the curse Gaston is a
single guy who can have any girl he
wants except for Belle he could continue
to date and live that bachelor life but
he wants a wife and he isn't settling
for just anyone
he is ready to be a father and take care
of a family strapping boys like Gaston
isn't afraid of commitment doesn't Belle
want someone who wants her there's also
one major point were overlooking the
Beast imprisoned above Belle and her
father he was going to lock Marissa way
forever maurice didn't do anything wrong
he was caught in a storm and was being
chased by evil wolves he was just
looking for shelter the beasts literally
has a whole castle he obviously learned
nothing from The Enchantress who cursed
him and if he was just worried that
maurice would tell people about him
why did he agree to let him go he just
wanted a prisoner but why imprisoning
people is not a good start to a healthy
relationship and he threatened to let
Belle starve just because she didn't
want to eat with a guy who took her
captive now that we figured out that
maybe Gaston isn't all that bad
let's look at some other reasons that
Val should have married Gaston this next
one is huge the French Revolution the
next reason that val should have married
gaston is going to require a bit of a
history lesson
this isn't your boring history class
let's just say that if Belle married the
Beast she would probably not have lived
very long as Danish Schwartz from the
observer points out in a PowerPoint
spells best chance at a happily ever
after would have been some marry Gaston
Beauty and the Beast takes place in the
late 18th century France we know this
from the Stiles and when the original
story was written with the
1700s were not a happy time for France
Gaston also says he fought in a war
which was probably the Seven Years War
so we have a pretty good idea of exactly
when the movie takes place there was a
lot of poverty in the 18th century
France but the nobility lived really
lush lives you saw that big feast at
Lumiere and the rest of the objects
served Belle that's pretty standard for
the Royals of France this time meanwhile
regular people could barely afford flour
to make bread people were starving and
the Royals wouldn't do anything after
the American Revolution was successful
the French decided enough was enough
they wanted a democracy to make everyone
more equal they were tired of starving
while the nobles were having huge feasts
and grand balls all the time but the
French Revolution turned really violent
there are reports that the streets of
Paris ran red we're talking horror movie
level violence the country went bankrupt
but the King continued to tax people to
live his lavish lifestyle all of the
other aristocrats had been largely
exempt from taxes but the people decided
it was time that the rich helped fix the
problem citizens stormed the castles and
estates of the rich they stole from them
and resorted to violence the Third
Estate which was all the regular people
valid to make change they stormed the
Bastille which is where a bunch of
weapons were kept then it got worse and
more violence eventually the king and
queen were sentenced to execution and
tons of nobles had similar sentences
during this time this is where the
phrase off with their heads comes from
it was not pretty if Belle had married
the Beast she would have been a princess
this was not a good time to be a royal
within just a few years they would have
lost all of their power they probably
would have lost a lot of their money and
their home and there's a really good
chance that they would have not survived
that's just sad Gaston on the other hand
would have survived he was a member of
the Third Estate and he was a war
veteran he would have not been a target
of the anti noble rioters and if a riot
had broken out he would have been able
to protect Belle now they wouldn't have
been able to know exactly what would
happen in France but she had to know
about the general unrest and how people
felt about the nobility she was a smart
girl
Marion Gaston would have protected her
future a lot better the Beast isn't real
this next theory will blow your mind
keep in mind that this theory only
applies to the animated movie and the
musical it does not work with the
live-action movie starring Emma Watson
this theory was published on reddit and
came from a user named Fox in the show
this person has concluded that the Beast
never existed and marrying a figment of
your imagination is possible first of
all let's look at all the ways that
Gaston and the beast are similar this is
really important to understand this
theory both Gaston and the beast are at
first undesirable to Belle they are both
not very nice people they don't read
Belle teaches the Beast to read well
here I'll help you
Gaston says he doesn't understand how
she understands books with no pictures
they are both violent and brutish they
don't act very smart and are very
superficial Belle loves to read fairy
tales the creator of this theory
believes that Belle actually married
Gaston and she imagines her life with a
beast that's how she imagines Gaston the
theory suggests that maurice actually
gave his blessing to Gaston and Belle's
marriage Val having no better options
marries Gaston she thinks he's pretty
awful but girls didn't always have a lot
of say in who they married back then
because she's unhappy and has an active
imagination she imagines the story of
Beauty and the beasts but Gaston is the
beasts that she changes and learns to
love the cast's where the Beast
supposedly lives is less than one day's
bride away from the village but none of
the villagers know about the prince
there if it's all in Belle's head
explains why the villagers aren't aware
of the castle but why would Belle
imagined that her father went through
all of that violence well she loves her
father but she is angry that he married
her off her conflicted feelings come out
in her made-up story
the castle also has all the things she
wants mrs. Potts is like a mother she
has friends there and it isn't the poor
provincial life that she hates so much
she ends up falling for the Beast
aka Gaston or maybe she just wants to
fall in love but she's worried that
Gaston will end up ruining it she's
created this elaborate fantasy in her
head to deal with her unhappiness and
conflicting emotions whoa
that makes the story way Saturn do you
think this theory that there is no beast
is true who do you think Belle should
have married sound off with your own
theories in the comment section I
don't deserve you yeah and that's it for
why Bell should have married Gaston in
Beauty and the Beast give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]